ich hoffe ihr lieb ich jetzt gar keine
facebook com
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
bin eigentlich und ich frage mich das
immer wieder nicht aber wer kann mir das
später dann aber wir erwarten dass für
alle die die regeln nicht kennen von dem
maße wie wir jetzt gleich die namen
einblenden dieses der jeweils andere für
uns überlegt hat die seht ihr dann die
werde jetzt auch noch mal da bleiben
erst mal 20 sekunden oder so nein die
werden genauso dann diesen kaymer bei
dir hier unten in der ecke klein und
beim wie in die fresse traveller keiner
sehen
so leute und dann kenne ich eigentlich
fünf staaten wichtig ist noch dass ihr
wisst man darf nur fragen stellen die
mit ja oder nein zu beantworten sind und
für jede jahr frage darf man noch eine
frage stellt wie die antwort man nicht
und wenn man den neuen antwort kastriert
auf seiner frage dann ist der nächste
dann weißt du willst du hast du mir
ausgedacht ja alles klar und pfiff im
sturm ähnlich überlegen ja nein nein das
war einfach pech du wirst du einer
unterhaltungs bilden das bleibt ja auch
männlich wirst du das gesagt bei
männlichen dann frag ich verbinde ich
comedian comedian eigentlich auch nicht
wirklich mache ich komme ja mach ich das
pc comedy das ist nicht ganz klar die
tschechen hatten hier finde ich bin ich
alleine auf meinem teller unterwegs nein
komme die kommen die uns macht muss
alter nicht an
ich habe nur mit ja beantwortet du hast
mir ich bin nicht alleine ich gefallen
das wird ein super 8 8 machst du kein
let's play wir noch krümel sogar machst
du wieder aufwachen heute machst du
wieder ab und zu ja dann nein also ja
gerade den kuchen heute hier am markt
der kuchen war gut deutsch spitz ab und
zu wieder machst du sport in einem video
nein ich kenne habe ich über
hunderttausend bis über eine million
also viele kannst dich an also gab es
über eine million der bullige wie schon
aus ja man die umc eine million dann
würde ich doch sagen bin ich einer von
den aids nein bereut ich dann rate ich
weiter mache ich musik habe ich über das
tor
unter 100
das liebste okay du bist eine ich bin
okay habe ich über zwei millionen aber
es würde mich wundern
ich kann bestimmt sagen als ob wie viel
comedy wie viel kommuniziert mehr als
einer person gibt es zwischen einer
million und zwei millionen abonnenten
100 die welche fallen euch ein comedy
plastischen 13 millionen in deutschland
echt krass das abo inflation und ich bin
nicht ich als ich gehöre nicht zu ich
glaube vielleicht vielleicht zur ein
komplett aber warte warte ich hab's noch
eine frage über zwei millionen mehr als
eine person am schluss noch nicht
gefallen ist
guter hinweis ich bin nicht in
deutschland
nein also bin ich in deutschland also
ich mache mache musik ab und zu wieder
knapp über 100.000 abonnenten hängt
meine musik mit lätz place zusammen dass
lukas ein rapper hat der monat 1100 9000
okay dann vielleicht hat er mich auch
gerade erst mal tot bin ich teil von
waikiki nehmen also auf was er noch kann
und was er richtig überlege würde habe
ich viel über 300.000 abonnenten über
300.000 glaube nicht
ich habe ich habe es versucht ich habe
versucht das steht noch drin und wenn er
direkt da ich auch nicht ich kann
parieren
sogar schon selbst schon dann schallt
von mir selbst ragt dann noch vielleicht
weiter frage
okay er geht auf youtube
ich habe nichts vergessen dass youtuber
ist es auch so sagt vergleich sagt doch
gleich lossurfen
also dass auch das internet so bastelt
internet so bist du schlecht er für das
zu schlecht wie du ja du hast über
300.000 krass den griff also mache ich
hier eigentlich nicht die eigentlichen
lichter klein
ok ok über zwei millionen deutscher
comedy channel nicht prime capital und
nicht bullshit tv herford der facc was
gibt es denn da noch über zu leben
hinterm mond alter über zwei millionen
zu krank bist du nicht multipel sonst
nicht kommen die wirklich stimmt gar
nicht meine ich betteln ableiter nein du
bist nicht ich bin es also los
ich glaube dass gerade wir glauben nicht
alt aber mehr als zwei personen nach
meinem channel
so lange überlegen
ja also ich werde jetzt gehört mehr als
eine person zum festen kern die
regelmäßige videos auftritt mehr als
eine okay mehr als zwei glaube nicht
okay vielleicht ja ich sage aber kannte
fach musik ist dann ist es nur ein zeit
passe youtube oder ist also ab bring ich
alben heraus kann sein kann sagen ich
mache auch musik aber ich bin ja
männlichsten bringen sonst war er in
mainstream okay
ich kann es kann sein dass ich diese
auch so was ja also ich finde das alles
klar
ich mache meinen ersten 3g
wie bist du geistig behindert alter ist
einfach nur scheiße willkommens nicht
darauf über zwei millionen yaman okay
also es gibt es nicht wollte die ist es
nicht egal ob 1 million für mich
vielleicht weiß man noch nicht ok water
fucking fragt was gibt es denn noch war
der wahl wahrscheinlich dich jetzt
gerade auf dem schlauch und bin
behindert kann man nicht ausschließen
was kann sein leute ich hoffe ihr jetzt
kein facebook macht mir kommen die ideen
tipps sind schon lange im biz lange ist
außenseiter
wir gedacht weil die draußen angenommen
ich hätte auch demonstriert